ah the voice of an angel
that's Kelly Ripa and Mark Consuelos is
18 year old daughter Lola showing off
her pipes on Instagram yeah I'm
definitely impressed
she's so spectacular Lola's family was
also very proud as they should be
Kelly commented quote you are gifted
while her younger brother Joaquin wrote
Wow
the best voice I've ever heard even
Camilla Mendez who plays marks daughter
on Riverdale left this sweet comment and
we know that had to have made Lola's day
I know that your daughter's a big burger
doll fan she loves it so now after one
commenter suggested that lola go on The
Voice another suggested American Idol
which you know probably makes a bit more
sense yes I can't wait I cannot wait to
see you there this is American Idol but
with or without Idol safe to say Lola is
making a name for herself in Hollywood
earlier this month she and mom Kelly hit
the red carpet in the cutest mini
dresses we inspire each other
Kelly and marks on Michael is also
pretty darn talented he appeared on
Riverdale last year playing a younger
version of his dad et recently sat down
with mark and Kelly where they talked
about Michael and Lola what advice have
you given both of them as they kind of
make their own way well I think you know
especially with the programs that
they're in is that the peers they're
their peers that they're going to school
with our people that they're going to be
working with so make connections
cultivate those relationships they're
also they're both very different they're
in both different disciplines and
they're both very different types of
people but I think what they have
learned so far in their young lives is
that you show up for people when they
show up for you and you show up and and
you don't you know never make a
commitment and and and then suddenly
something a better offer comes you have
to pay the percentages of success is
that game percent of the game is just
showing up or something something yeah I
love them all right guys that's it for
today for all the latest on the
Consuelos family make sure that you keep
it locked to ET until next time I'm
Katie Krause and bye for now
[Music]